did you know what that plastics could be
hiding in your beauty products many body
products contain plastics specifically
micro plastics their plastics that are
really tiny
I mean smaller than a grain of rice tiny
cosmetics body washes and toothpastes
are some of the biggest culprits for
containing micro plastics often used as
exfoliant
they're a cheaper alternative to natural
ingredients used for the same purpose
first let's talk toothpaste see all
those little blue dots sparkling like
stars yeah those could be plastics
toothpastes that look like this may
contain tiny bits of good old
polyethylene the world's most popular
form of plastic next we have face and
body washes this stuff makes you feel
clean but how previously it was with
tiny pearls of polypropylene another
commonly used plastic material in
microbeads these dots of polypropylene
are what exfoliate your skin and open up
your pores and finally cosmetics blush
concealer foundation mascara lipstick
and eye liner almost every type of
makeup product can be made with plastic
the usual suspects like polyethylene and
polypropylene are used but so are other
plastics like polyethylene terephthalate
which is found in glitter yes glitter is
really just shiny pieces of plastic so
every time you brush your teeth shower
or wash off makeup you could be sending
all those microplastics down the drain
and into rivers lakes and oceans but
even before the micro plastics are
washed down the drain they can still
pose a danger
inhaling fine particulates like micro
plastics has been linked to asthma heart
disease and cancer thankfully measures
are being taken to help mitigate the
world's microplastics problem in 2015
the United States passed a law called
the microbead free waters Act it has
already begun to phase out the use of
microbeads in toothpastes and to rinse
off cosmetics manufacturers are already
using natural alternatives to micro
plastics and you can also make a
difference when purchasing cosmetics
soaps and toothpastes read the packaging
if you see polyethylene polypropylene or
polyethylene terephthalate you might
want to consider a more environmentally
friendly option while it will be nearly
impossible for us to live 100% free of
plastics thinking twice about how we use
plastics in our day-to-day lives makes a
huge difference for our bodies and our
planet
[Music]
[Music]